لم تسعف الظروف ولا الاوراق الثبوتيه
الشابه حمزه الصفواني البالغ 17 عاما
بالعوده الى السعوديه واستكمال اوراقه
الرسميه والعيش برفقه عائله ابي حيث توفي
تحت انقاذ احدى البنايات بمدينه انطاكيا
التركيه التركيه العربيه التقت والده حمزه
الذي روى قصه اقامه وحياه ابنه هناك
[موسيقى]
قطعه مني كيف حتى الحين ابكي عليه ولدي
والله كل شويه ابكي بس الحمد لله
بهذه الكلمات المؤثره تحدث مصطفى الصفواني
والد الشاب حمزه الذي توفي في مدينه
انطاكيا التركيه تحدث لكاميرا العربيه حول
تفاصيل وفاته جراء الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب المدينه
بالاربع ايام
اربع ايام عزيت خلاص
قبل الزلزال والله والله والله والله
في نفس الليله وانا قاعد على سجادتي قبل
الفجر قلت ان شاء الله اجيب ولدي قبل لا
يصير شي مشاكل هناك في تركيا بيجي بيجي ان
شاء الله بس بعد القضاء والقذا الحمد لله
والشكر يعطيك العافيه
يا رب هذا الاب كان ينتظر عوده ابنه الى
حضنه بعد غيابه لسنوات طويله حيث عاش حمزه
مع والدته في سوريا قبل ان ينتقل الى
تركيا قبل عامين تمهيدا لعودته الى عائله
ابيه في صفوه شرقيه السعودي
حتى حركاتة ابدا يعني امس جاي احنا في
القبر ومسوي عزا في الليل
مدرسه
الحمد لله الله يعطيه والله ياخذ تقريبا
قبل شهر كان تواصل معاي
والحمد لله رب العالمين على كل حال ما
نقدر نقول غير الحمد لله كنا نترقب جيته
في اقرب وقت ممكن
بس ان شاء الله
وشاءت الاقدار والحمد لله على كل حال ما
نقدر نقول غير الحمد لله مصطفى تواصل مع
ابنه المتوفي قبل ايام قليله من رحيله
مبينا انه كان يعيش برفقه جدته من امه في
انطاكيا التي نجت باعجوبه من الزلزال بعد
اخراجها من تحت الانقاض راحوا يوم الجمعه
في الصباح راحوا والله فتشل شافوا هذه
شافوه
ام احمدك ظاهره جدته ظاهر راسها
وقعدوا يحفروا ولا طلعوها في ودوها
المستشفى الحمد لله ما فيها اي شيء
ولا حمزه قال توفى
الحمد لله
حمزه ليس الابن الوحيد الذي فقد حياته في
عائله مصطفى هناك ابن اخر له توفي غرقا
قبل عده سنوات بمدينه صفوان ولا يزال
مصطفى الصفواني صابرا على هذا الفقد رغم
حزنه العميق الواضح على ملامحه المنهكه
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مدينه صفوه العربيه